[Music]
my name is grace I'm a cloud solutions
architect based out of the London office
if you were wondering where my weird
accent came from and I'm here to talk to
you about designing and implementing
disaster recovery systems in GCP no
matter where your production is and be
that on GCP itself on-premises or in
another cloud so when it comes to dr
there tends to be a number of
three-letter acronyms or tear lays so i
just want to start to kind of go through
some of those and i will like to start
by actually distinguishing between
disaster recovery and high availability
think about high availability as being
for a micro disaster a single web server
dies in a farm of web servers or a
single disk in the same did think of
disaster recovery would being when you
actually have to failover to a recovery
site because you're no longer able to
serve your production environment out of
your production environment so there are
four Ganahl but they are related hae
will actually drive what your dr
scenario will look like particularly if
you're running your production on GCP
RTO and RPO these are obviously the
three-letter acronyms that everybody
knows and will understand when it comes
to art and they are
think of RTO and being the recovery time
objective been how long will it take you
to get your application back up and
running again
okay recovery point objectives think
about that as like how much data are you
actually willing or able to account
actually lose think about going back to
that last backup you took or you know
the backup and the transaction log files
okay so Artie that's smaller the RTO and
RPO value it has an asymptotic impact on
your bottom line
are ye is likely to cost more because
you can have to put more rebuilding more
resilience into your environment SLA and
that's nestled O's okay
they're often they're often conflated
but they are two separate things the SLO
is the motional component
okay so here the measurable component is
how many how many bowls of cat food does
this cat got and obviously how often I
give them the cat food an SLA is the
agree is the agreement the SLO is
feeding to that SLA and also the our to
our RTO and RPO values feeding to the s
ellos now obviously I'm not a great
contract term negotiator because it's
gonna be one really fat cat okay okay so
moving on so I just want to kind of get
you thinking about D our patterns before
we move on and start actually looking at
some of the features that we can have
them can help you so and I'm gonna draw
an analogy with having a journey and
having a flat tire okay so if you're
driving along and you have a flat tire
you have no spare you come to a complete
halt you have to phone somebody up you
have to get them to come out to you they
have to replace the tire okay that's a
pretty cold pattern because you're not
that ready for that scenario however if
you've got spare yes you need to halt
but you've got everything you need to
actually recover and continue on your
journey you change the tire yourself you
don't need to wait for anybody else then
you can carry on and at the other end
the hot pattern would be the effect if
you were running on flecked run-flat
tires
run-flat tires means if it has a
puncture you can still continue moving
maybe a bit slower and obviously when
you get to the other end of your journey
you'll change it to a proper tire but
you know you're ready doesn't really
doesn't stop you it just makes you slow
down a bit
okay so talked about patterns talked
about the tear laid you need to do some
planning okay so you need to start by
defining your recovery goals to think
about this think about your actual
application because your application
will actually define what those recovery
goals are so here we've got three
different examples of different types of
them applications back to processing
that doesn't tend to be time critical so
you can do things and this is a data
proc one you can do things like take
advantage of preemptable VMS preemptable
VMS at the end it's like standard VMS
but you can get them a lot lower
but we will reclaim them up to 24 hours
so with the batch with this sort of as
the batch processing architecture you
can have a mix of standard IND and
preemptable 's so if the preemptable
gets reclaimed you can if you're using
checkpoints you can either continue
processing that little bit of processor
and workload from that point or you can
start again you need to paint but the
point is it's a fact that it's kind of a
warmish pattern because you can still
carry on it slows you down you can carry
on ecommerce has different RTO and RPO
values throughout the application so the
actual user journey that's hot
it needs to be available all the time
you know it's too easy you know users
today have a very short attention span
and they will move on okay but the email
that that notifies them that they've
bought something that's not that
important because they know they've
bought it yes they'll be expecting an
email at some point but not immediately
you know it's decoupled it's fine and
you know the recommendation engine that
that could actually be out of date by a
couple of days yeah it's not great but
it's not critical to the journey and
then the other extreme the encoding and
delivery everything's hot you need to
have resilience everywhere because
people want to watch their films the
encoding is got happen for the platform
so you can see that how looking at your
application will define your are your
recovery goals so you identify the DR
patterns that are applicable you need to
design for end-to-end recovery are you
not just backing up but you need to
actually be able to go back to your
production environment when it's up and
running okay make your task specific
saying run say run the recovery solution
solute scenario isn't good enough you
need to actually provide instructions
because you don't know who's going to be
there to do the recovery it might be
somebody who's not that familiar say
look onto the server change directory to
the digit dr4
folder and then run run the file help me
please Doris Age with the command to do
that implement control measures okay you
don't really want a disaster so you know
if you're taking advantage of the
self-healing features within the
platform especially if your productions
on GCP
eh-eh if you can support making sure
your communication lines are sorted out
make sure you know who to contact in GCP
make sure you've got your with your
contact details are up to date and make
sure we turn alee that the contact lines
are sorted out very far your software
licensing sometimes you're not able to
run your software you're running a
production in a warm standby mode
you need to double check those licenses
so if you're using third-party packages
really make sure that you're you're not
you're running it in the correct way
that it's allowed so what happens if you
can't connect to GCP okay if your
production environments down how are you
going to deploy if you're deploying from
production to your dr scenario implement
maybe more than one data recovery path
okay think about different ways of
community how you're going to connect to
TCP in an event for disaster test your
plan regularly okay you can use things
like deployment manager to bring up a
serve your environment and bring it down
it's something that makes dr in the
cloud so much more compelling because
it's just so much easier to do this
security in your dr plan okay you need
to maintain permission consistency
between your on-prem and GCP okay you've
set up controls on prim or in another
cloud and you need to mirror that when
you fail over the permissions you put in
place shouldn't be forgotten about make
sure your users can log into the dr
environment don't expect them to be able
to log into the dr environment for the
first time when you have a disaster
practice get them to understand what
they need to do train them to use the dr
environment things will be different
particularly fits on premium and going
to tcp if it's within GCP and they're
used to that then obviously it's not a
big deal but you know if they're used to
logging on to their own primp stuff you
need to think about how you get them to
log on elsewhere mirror your security
controls in GCP okay so if you classify
your data and you've got particularly
controlled around that mirror that in
GCP okay so you need to understand how
to map your
security controlled to using the things
like I am in GCP and managers to get
your secrets properly configuration
files if you're running the app download
your service account Keys manage those
properly as well use encryption things
like that okay so now I'm going to just
go through and start talking to you
about the dr building blocks and these
are features of these platforms that
lend themselves to dr and hey CheY ok
stackdriver it's it's often the the
first sign of a problem is with your
monitors and logs so stackdriver works
across AWS and GCP uptime monitors
alerts log in and error reporting I'll
come back to cloud storage we'll dig
into that bit easier it's a object store
for things like backups data files
cloudiness it allows you to
programmatically change DNS values so in
the event of a failover you can get it
to automatically with an automated
failover script change that changed they
records to point elsewhere so cloud
storage has a number of storage classes
click on their line a cold line are
particularly suited for dr scenarios
cloud load balancing so very very common
pattern is to have a single IP address
that france either a single servant
instance or multiple instances so cloud
load balancing gives you a sink or any
class type IP address it tends to be
integrated with managed instance groups
managed instance groups allow you to
scale up and down identically configured
instances you and and so that therefore
it's only a single IP address or you can
have its so it only runs up a and
instant a sync an instance sorry a
single serving their applications you
can have it set so it only serves them
one instance at a time and if that
instance has a problem and replace it
but it has exactly the same IP address
so compute engine again as you'd expect
i'll come back to that because it is the
workhorse that and cloud storage tends
to be the word
course for dr kubernetes engine which is
our managed kubernetes service and
you've probably heard a lot about
kubernetes over this event so i'm not
going to say too much but basically it
allows you have the same workload on
multiple platforms cloud deployment
manager is kind of actually kind of it's
a key feature this allows you to create
repeatable consistent simpler
environments so you can define your
recovery environment you can insert
deployment manager in when there's a
disaster you can bring it up also when
you want to test you can bring it up and
bring down because you only pay for what
you use so test test test so let's have
a look at some of the components of
compute engine when you start up an
instance you start from what's called an
image so this image can be fully baked
so where it's got everything corn it has
less external with dependencies so maybe
for your web servers that's a kind of a
good gudem example they have fastboot
times the trade-off is that your that is
your version control so therefore you're
going to have to manage more of those
images and the other end you can have
you know start off from a one of the
public images or or your own your a
public image and then you layer
everything on top so there's more
dependencies it has a slower boot time
and then there's the middle ground where
you may have all your applications done
and then you only actually do load up
the updated files as and when needed
depending on what that instance is doing
depends on your of which which of those
you will choose you know so database
probably doesn't need to be fully baked
you probably set it up and then you just
do upgrades persistent disks so piston
distant block storage that are attached
to instances to type standard and
regional so standard zone also it will
exist in one's own regional there's it
uses twice as much storage because
there's synchronous replication across
two zones in the region okay you need to
set the permissions you need to take the
grant the permissions to attach
this two instances you could set the
auto delete flag on the disk two forks
sorry so that means it won't when the
instance is destroyed that disk will
continue to live on so you can attach
another instance to that into that disk
that's there and also don't forget to
mount the disk from within the instance
so at this point because you probably
fed up of hearing me for talk for so
long I'm now going to invite up Chris
from cloud into your who's who's
hopefully going to give you a demo of
how they can actually help you with your
dr scenario thanks Chris if those upper
essentially cloud indoor was founded in
2012 as long as I'm here grazed 2012 out
of Tel Aviv by four four Israelis who
were essentially entrepreneur serial
entrepreneurs since then we've grown to
four different offices three here in
North America Boston New York and Los
Angeles we started with 18 million
dollars in funding that was just our
first and only round of funding by
strategic investors and an obviously
notable venture capital firms as you can
see some of these investors actually
have disaster recovery or backup
products built in so it's interesting to
note those I'm not big on logo dropping
obviously but it is nice to look at the
ecosystem of our customers and channel
partners the diversity of it the size
and obviously the different verticals I
think that what this speaks to is is our
flexibility in terms of working with
with organizations of different sizes
and scopes and focuses we also pay close
attention to our channel partners to
make sure that they have all the tools
available to them to deliver a valuable
product to their customers so cloud or
essentially is a three-legged monster in
terms of solution use cases however the
the underlying technology is is
identical it's exactly the same with
just a couple different variations in
terms of workflow or or executions
from a from a diversity standpoint with
cloud we want to make sure that we are
we're selling diversity and redundancy
that we have a diverse group of
different cloud providers kind of in our
arsenal so we work obviously closely
with GCP and and the other public cloud
providers out there so that we allow
diversity across clouds and within
clouds so how does it work
the technology from a very granular
fundamental standpoint these steps are
what we're gonna ask you to do and what
the executions are on our customers end
which is install an agent initially it's
an OS based very lightweight kernel
kernel agent that we install on each
machine whether it be virtual physical
in the cloud or on Prem
well that agents going to do is connect
with our management console where within
the console you're able to configure a
blueprint which essentially defines the
resources within GCP that are required
so then spin up those target instances
and make them available for production
as Grace was saying test test test
one big value prop for cloud in doors
our ability to test at any frequency
that our customers would like they can
do on a Friday afternoon before happy
hour they can do it weekly monthly by
annually I know that's part of most dr
planning so it's important to understand
that you can test by the click of a
button whenever is whatever's required
and then once the testing is you know
completed we want to do a very beginning
of implementation and then obviously
always an often but at that point we're
able to failover and we have those
workloads available no matter what in ng
CP come time for a failure or or to run
these drills so here's kind of a
high-level overview of the architecture
and I think what's important to note is
on the left side what you're going to
see is is your source infrastructure so
whether that be an on-prem data center
whether that be a GC p production
environment in east or west or central
so you have obviously your machines
working here we're going to deploy these
agents on any Windows or Linux workload
or machine with all of the volumes
attached to it it's going to identify
itself up to our our management console
which you see up top there where that
console is going to have is obviously
the blueprint piece but all that
takes his metadata so the size and
quantity of those discs with what
they're going to what we're then going
to do with that through that management
Constable's cloud indoors going to
manage and orchestrate our staging area
the middle piece essentially all that is
low cost low compute resources I believe
it's an n1 small or n1 standard that we
that we provision for for the
replication servers and those servers
are just recipients for the agent
traffic that then have I believe 15 to 1
ratio from replication server to two
volumes attached and that's where your
data is going to sit so at this point
you kind of ignore the the far right
target network because this is kind of
business as usual in terms of our
disaster recovery you're going to see a
total cost of ownership reduction of
typically about 80 percent versus legacy
dr architectures so then when we
actually need to run a test or when we
need to failover in the in the case of a
disaster Condor is going to
automatically orchestrate all the
necessary resources and spin up that
that target environment in production
with sub-second rpoS and RTOS when
you're done we fail back we just switch
the architecture around source becomes
target target becomes source you can
fill back whether it be deltas or full
bare-metal and then we just turn down
that that second instance so you don't
essentially pay for it on an ongoing
basis okay pop into here into the demo
so what you see here essentially is the
the management console it's very
simplistic a lot of a lot of cloud and
or by our approach has always been
simplicity so to kind of dig into this
for the sake of time we have this list
of these list of machines an application
server on the front end that essentially
is running a wordpress blog and a my
sequel database on the back end you see
here on the on the replication process
this is the stage that's in so it's in
CDP mode so you having a real-time copy
residing in that low-cost staging area
and dig into this a little bit so and
this is essentially the that metadata I
was talking about this is the only data
that cloud indoor is ever gonna take or
look at or have access to we don't ever
look at
look at the data have access to the data
within those workloads so let's go ahead
and pop over here to our WordPress this
is not the WordPress okay this could be
interesting
this is the site but not the press let
me figure out how to pull this up
essentially what we'll do is we'll see
it in job Progress and I want to make
sure we don't run over time here but
this is our this is our work this is our
WordPress that we would be typically
updating so I would put on there
whatever time it is 456 p.m. and then I
would go into here select these two
instances and launch these machines you
have two options test and recovery the
only difference here is that with
recovery it's essentially going to
prepare those instances for a failback
scenario as well we're gonna run this
test just gonna make sure I want to do
it here you have all your rpoS so these
are different recovery points that you
have available to you so essentially
it's every ten minutes for an hour every
hour for a day every day for a month and
and our new release will be having
customizable rpoS as well
recovery points continue attest so you
see up top his machines have been
launched and the job progress will
provide more details so while we're
waiting for these to launch both kind of
take a look at this progress a job it
started and we're waiting for the latest
snapshot so right now what that's doing
is preventing provisioning all those
resources within that GCP environment
it's orchestrating all the necessary
production resources and converting with
our automated machine conversion
converting any unlike source
infrastructure into something that's
workable and GCP so if you've a
non-prime environment that's a little
bit legacy like a server 2008 or
something and we need to convert some of
those some of those hypervisors or
workloads into something different
within the cloud within GCP then they'll
convert that for you all automatically
on the back end so let's drill down into
these machines one more time and just
show you a little bit about the
blueprint that i was speaking of so
within these blueprints this is where we
are defining essentially those resources
that are required
it's just machine name quantity size of
the disks essentially what we want to
run those on so we're right here we have
an n1 standard but obviously there's
there's different variations depending
on the complexities the size and
different variations of your of your
source workload
you can customize the name of these
servers so different different projects
or different you know sequel databases
might might be ten fifteen five thousand
that you're but you're managing so in
here you can customize those we define a
subnet so essentially as a private
network for the exclusive use of cloud
indoor and these in this dr or this
replication process private IP alas and
public IPS as well the discs required on
the network side you have the ability to
throttle bandwidth so during the initial
sync obviously is we're gonna going to
utilize those resources the most but
after that if we wanted to just make
sure that productions never interrupt
from a bandwidth perspective you can
throttle this up and down depending on
needs but typically the default is is
just fine the dashboard essentially is a
high-level overview of the licenses you
have allocated to your pool licenses
what's an initial sync mode so the
initial seeding of the data into the
low-cost staging area and what's ready
which means it's in full CDP mode and
you have a a real-time copy just waiting
for failover waiting for that execution
to take place typically app between
these two phases it pops into the
require attention so after the initial
sync it will say require attention which
just means we highly recommend that you
do some testing on this again we're
always in promote test test test as well
the audit log essentially is you know an
overview of all the different
transactions taking place you've seen
the you know we've run the demo a few
times in the last couple days it also
shows test launches you can delete the
replication so all of this is kind of
taking place in the backend giving you a
bit of an audit trail for compliance
reasons there for internal best
practices on the setup and info you have
the machines associated with this
project
your GCP credentials these credentials
again go back to that kind of defining
where we're going what we're doing with
it replication settings in terms of what
your sources and what your target is so
in this case we have I believe its AWS
is our demo environment to Google
Central the replication servers host
names etc so everything that's sitting
on that source from the OS level from
the disk level is being replicated
fully every setting every security group
sub bets
dis sizes all of it is completely just
in again in real-time a block level
replications taking plays ready to be
restored
based on that blueprint definition some
of these are just other settings that
they can go into female notifications
with whatnot so to add a new machine we
go up here to how to add new machines
and it's as simple as deploying an agent
that agent immediately syncs with the
GCP cloud environment that you've
defined and goes into sync mode without
any further action required and to just
get back to the machines and you'll
always again see which phase they're in
here when they were tested it looks like
we actually launched our sequels so far
and our target machines have been
launched so you can see that in here we
have an RTO of 750 6:00 p.m. to 801 it's
about four minutes and we have a fully
functional what would be a word press
with it with an update to it executed
and in fill-in failover mode so from
here again until your source machines
are back up and running we can fail back
at any given time by flipping that
architecture and then the best part
about it is we select these machines and
we delete these target instances saving
us all the money associated with GCP
resources being consumed thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
mostly with us okay okay so continuing
on so yeah okay who couldn't be type of
time okay so the first thing that you
need to think about when connecting to
juicy peas connectivity you need to
think about what's going to be passed
across your bandwidth you need to think
about what else is sharing that
bandwidth typically we see one of the
flavors of interconnect so this helps
this is important because it helps you
get over the variances of transferring
stuff across the internet okay it's it
you've got more control over the hops so
once you've decided on what can how
you're going to connect you they need to
think about how you do the transfer
initially you tend to seed your
environment so you have a large amount
of data so do something like that your
google transfer appliance and then once
you've got that seeded and your
applicate you've got your warm standby
or whatever on the other on GC p you can
then use maybe something like GS u2 or
or the Google transfer service to move
over incremental updates so there's
typically data involved when you do dr
so I tend to put it into two lots what I
call data backups and database backups
database data backups I just have been
essentially a discrete amount of data
copy from one place to another place
okay so typically cloud storage where's
database backups tend to be more more
complicated because you're copying over
the backup of your database using the
system that your database engine uses to
create the backup and also the
transaction log files particularly for a
relational databases plus you've got to
make sure that in GCP you've got a
mirrored the ability to run them to
write the correct version of the
database server so that you can actually
restore the backups and the transaction
log file so it tends to be more more
complicated and the key thing there is
the recovery point objective so you've
got to make sure that you're also
thinking about getting your transaction
log files over good cadence
a typical pattern third er is a Ted
storage pattern so traditionally this
means tearing data from local fastest to
slower cheaper DISA T move move along in
DCP it's slightly different so you have
the vast persistent disks being the
faster local disks and then you tear it
to cloud storage so they can they their
and performances but is the same for
both of those
and you tear but it's as you don't need
access to the data as quickly it becomes
cheaper to store on cold line or an
airline okay and just to show you that
the patterns are the same whether you do
it on Prem or or not here we have a
tiered storage pattern whereby you've
got cloud interconnect connecting to
your on-prem to GCP you've got your
emperor on premises ohms storage array
and you're tearing data off to a
regional bucket and then to near line or
a cold line bucket you could you could
actually decide that you want to change
the class of the object when it gets to
regionals to the regional block bucket
what I find is that most people tend to
actually just want another bucket to do
the tearing because it makes it
logically just it's easier to see okay
so so GCP has a number of manage
databases and this they're designed for
scale and volume so they're managed
they're designed for but managing
petabytes of database so you know laws
of physics doing backup and restores of
huge amounts of data is just gonna take
an awful long time so you need to think
about how you design those databases
maybe have tables that are designed so
that you've got them in dates so if
there's a corruption and you know for a
particular date you only have to worry
about that slither of your database
these these systems tend to be related
replicated under underneath anyway but I
know we do understand people want a
better level of comfort you can export
things to cloud storage or you could
keep the raw files maybe you only need
two exact days bit of data to actually
up and running so you just need to think
it through I'd also like to call out
here clout composure this is our manager
Pat Geum airflow using a directed
acrylic graph it allows you to design a
flow for moving data around so it can
use it and it had operators which are
plugins to toot for things like bigquery
and cloud storage so you can use that to
move data around from cloud bigquery and
cloud storage to get a backup system
that way ok
fun bit we'll look over some
architectures let's start by looking at
production on GC P H a first you need to
think about high variability when you're
designing your application on GC P
because you know they've got these
features built in their zones and
regions so we talked about we've talked
about sorry going back we've talked
about most of these briefly so I can
whiz on the security controls you don't
need to worry about so much about
because you're in DCP anyway so you
would have defined your security
controls and they'll be easy to apply to
your new environment here's an
interesting dr a scenario you're running
your web servers out of these in GCE
and if for some reason you and you've
also got a static website on cloud
storage that's sitting there looking
interesting say there's a problem with
serving out of your web service at GCE
then what you can do is you can flip
cloud DNS to point to your static
website if your web servers haven't
actually got that many moving parts bit
of JavaScript static home website is
actually a really cost effective way of
getting you up and getting something up
and running you could of course do H a
web surfing application ok
so here we've got we're using a regional
manager instance groups and as instances
across all the zones in that in the
region if one of the region if one of
the zones has a problem then you know it
will start up any an instant so you can
still have your load in one of the other
weather zones at the backend we're using
cloud sequel and it's doing semi
asynchronous replication to the replicas
in the other zone when there's a problem
it will automatically failover
yes your current connections will be
lost but they will be reconnected but
crucially you're still serving data I
talked about the single IP address this
is where this example comes in so you
have a single running server at any one
point typically for a database maybe for
an application middleware type service
in the event of a problem the you've
taken snapshots of this persistent disk
in the event of a problem the snapshot
creates a disk in another zone I could
have used regional persistent disk here
as well so that's another alternative
the reason you use snapshots here is
because standards erm persistent disks
are zonal you'd also take a firm but
don't get me wrong you would take
snapshots of the regional as well but
the the mechanism works different I
mentioned deploy it you could see
deployment manager on the list of the
building block tier deployment manager
is here used to bootstrap the managed
instance group and also to inject to
start up a HTTP server where you are
echoing your custom matrix to that
status that driver can can receive and
then they're actually kind of helps you
into that which actually allows it to
indium realize when there's a problem
with the actual application sometimes
the instance might be alright but it's
the application you're worried about the
productions on-premises this is all
about connectivity really cloud storage
and partners we've got some fantastic
partners you've seen one we've got
another one coming up later to do
another demo because I like people to
see demos and then there's a security
considerations this is something that
you need to really think through you
need to think about mapping
your security controls and the
permissions your users have to GCP so I
spoke about that in the planning stage a
compute engine and kubernetes engines
tends to be the computer I see a lot in
this environment here we have a warm
standby setup you're running production
out of your datacenter you'll notice
that we're actually and replicating data
to a database on GCP that instance is
quite small it's just it's just sized
and
to run the minimal to take the
replicated data I've chosen what so when
in the event of a problem cloud DNS
points to web servers that have been
created by snapshots
I chose snapshots here because if this
is a fast-moving org in this example and
they're constantly changing the the web
service and snapshots or the quickest
way you could also chosen custom images
as a way to do that okay
and then obviously you can also take the
proposed database to take production
workloads you can enlarge in it so it
can I cope with you production workloads
and you can have hot h a across GC p and
on-premises if you do this make sure
you've got something that has a weighted
is able to work with weighted records so
you can distribute traffic across
premises and at this point I would like
to introduce Brian from actifi oh and
let's hope the demo gods are still with
us who will also share talk to you about
how they can help you with your dr
environment thank you thank you very
much so I'll start off with just a few
brief slides then we'll jump right into
the demo in the interest of time I'm
from actifi Oh act if you as a company a
software company started in 2009 that
was created to really modernize the way
customers manage data and what our
software delivers is what our customers
refer to as data as a service allowing
customers to access the data they need
wherever they need it for multiple
different use cases data protection
disaster recovery certainly but even
things like test and development DevOps
and analytics use cases today we're
gonna focus on disaster recovery in GCP
so let's jump right into it the way
Activia works it's a little bit
different than the previous solution
that you saw we managed discrete
application consistent images of
different applications in the
environment it might be a virtual
machine it might be an Oracle database
on a physical server it might be a
sequel server or something like that but
all the different workloads that we
manage including you
things like ASAP Hana everything we do
is incremental forever updates moving
only the changes as efficiently and as
you possibly can using incremental
changes in compression to very
efficiently move data from wherever it
is on pram or maybe another cloud into
its destination like GCP so everything
we do is discrete images app consistent
which is important for us but but it's
not real-time or CDP it's going to be
job based and you know our POS of along
the lines of 15 minutes is is what we
advertise an Activia software runs
natively in GCP it runs on premises it
runs anywhere the data is and takes this
application consistent data and provides
access to it wherever you'd like to use
it and so for the dr scenario in into
Google cloud platform we really got two
different ways we can do it Activia was
all about letting customers manage their
data independent of the infrastructure
involved whether that's on pram or
whether that's in the cloud and so we've
got two ways to do this the first way is
our higher performance method and that
is the customer is going to deploy
actifi oh this is add er to the cloud
scenario so the workloads on Prem at the
customer data center and we're going to
do dr to GCP so the customer would
deploy an Activia virtual appliance in a
hypervisor of their choice on Prem we're
gonna capture those changes
incrementally forever we're going to
provide access to the data locally for
local recoveries as grace mentioned
that's certainly important I'm going to
avoid the dr event as long as you can if
you can access it locally great but
obviously to get it into GCP we're gonna
replicate that compressed encrypted
incrementally forever so it's very very
efficient on the land and in GCP we're
gonna send that to an instance of
Activia software in this case our
virtual appliance which we call sky it's
going to be running in GCP it's going to
receive the data and we're going to
store those application consistent
images in the infrastructure of your
choice for the highest performance it
would be a Google persistent disk you
can use a spinning disk you can use
flash storage or SSD if you like and
then from there we're going to provision
the data into existing virtual machines
or even create a new virtual machine
which is what we'll show you in the
demonstration
that's the the higher performance option
which comes with a little bit additional
infrastructure cost right for you know
for that performance for the Google
persistent disk that goes with it and
the compute you know running Activia
software in the cloud we have another
interesting architecture here as well
where we can do the same thing without
running any compute in the cloud we're
gonna take the data from our software on
Prem and just stick it directly into
object storage object storage is really
really cool not only for disaster
recovery but also for data protection
which is another use case that active
feel solves for where we can keep the
most recent copy and object storage we
keep the copy from 30 years ago if you
want to because it's very very cost
effective just by simply incrementally
updating those blocks and you don't have
to run any computing GCP including the
activity or software until the time of a
disaster where you'd spin up Activia
software pointed at the object bucket
write the new your line or cold line and
we'd be off and running with recoveries
so provides a slightly slower lower
performance level but still gives you
that that ability to do you know
recoveries for dr as well as backup
scenarios in the cloud which is really
cool so at this point let's jump to the
demonstration if you could please switch
over to the to the laptop perfect so
this is our activity Oh user interface
and trying to make up a little bit of
time here so I go well ative lee quickly
this this is this interface shows the
data that we're managing on Prem and in
the cloud it's based on SLA s or service
level agreements here you can see we're
capturing the data every eight hours in
this case we're keeping three days of
history local for local recoveries and
then we're streaming it up into the
cloud actually two different ways we're
keeping the most recent version on
higher performance disk and in this case
we're also doing daily you know versions
for 60 days of history in GCP on near
line or cold line object storage as well
so we've already done that through the
magic of television here I'm jumping
over to this environment and I'm going
to show you a virtual machine this is a
VMware virtual machine on Prem called
demo sequel one and I'm going to click
access my data here there's all kinds of
things you can do but keeping it short
and sweet here
I'm going to show you the recovery
points that we have in the cloud we'll
take the most recent one and I could
present that data into a running vm if I
were to have a VM running in GCP I could
simply present the data into it in a
couple of minutes which would be that
screen which I didn't mean to click what
I wanted to do with the different screen
so apologies here go back to access and
what I'm going to do is recover the
system we don't have the VM let's take
this VMware VM from on-prem that we've
replicated into GCP and let's make it
into a GC PBM so I'm going to come in
here I'm going to call this demo sequel
one in GCP I've got some options here
including providing authentication right
over the JSON file it's got the the
credentials for this particular area in
region and zone and all that good stuff
and in GCP and I'm just gonna click the
button and what this is going to do is
essentially start a job that's going to
take the data we already have
orchestrate with the API of GCP and
create a virtual machine from that from
that data that was a VMware VM on-prem
just you know just a few moments ago so
I've got a little job monitor here which
is right on this window and I've got a
compute engine right here and so what
I'm going to do is looking at GCP I'm
going to filter this for demo and this
will just take a couple of minutes we
basically provision the virtual machine
copy the system state information onto
it right all the windows you know
registry information and boot
information essentially taking a vanilla
Windows image in GCP and turning it into
your image from the on-prem virtual
machine so let's just take a few moments
to see the our new virtual machine show
up so I will impatiently click the
refresh button as you do in a live
demonstration there it is there we go
so there's demo sequel 1 powering on and
the process continues from there in just
a few moments we'd have a virtual
machine running in GCP that was on Prem
in a in a VMware hypervisor previously
if you want some more information we're
at the booth downstairs on the first
floor of this building so I will hand it
back to grace and thank you very much
thank you
okay so in the interest of time I'll
whiz on so thank you very much again
production on another cloud this is all
about common tooling so kubernetes and
you know I'm not going to add to that
there's some great great talks about
kubernetes that can do more justice than
I can but you know you can run it a
chrome frame on another cloud and on GCP
various managed services cloud storage
you now Amazon s3 compatibility you can
use boto which is a Python tooling that
allows you to write them objects to both
cloud storage and s3 with the same
tooling again there's connectivity and
you need to be able to map these
security controls from one to the other
so just to wrap up a few tips food when
you're doing gnome fideya identify your
RTO values per system and within the
system identify your dependencies they
may not always be obvious understand the
repeatable architectural patterns so
like when I talk about tiered storage
think about how you can apply them I
find it helps to list out the security
considerations permissions as well as
the controls you need to apply and
define how you will deploy your
deployment that your your deploy to your
dr environment on GCP ie remember if
your production environment isn't
available how are you going to get
updates to your dr environment that may
be run in production for longer than you
expect and test your plans regularly you
can now you only pay for what you use
you can use deployment manager to treat
your infrastructure as code so do that
and GCP for dr y total cost of ownership
no have to invest upfront in mostly I do
infrastructure is easy to carry out fire
drills
test test test I know I keep saying it
we really do it and no matter where your
production is held the same approaches
apply obviously there differences but
it's the same approaches and once you
start using GCP for dr it does actually
make the migration path easy so thank
you for listening
you
[Music]